One night, a little swallow flew over the city.
He was in love with the most beautiful reed.
"Will you come away with me?" He asked her.
The reed shook her head.
She wanted to stay at home in the river.
"Then, I shall leave you," the swallow said.
"Goodbye!" And he flew away.
All day long he flew and at nighttime, he arrived at the city.
Then, he saw the statue of the Happy Prince in the center of the town.
"I will stay there," he said.
"It is a good place with plenty of clean air."
The Happy Prince's face was so beautiful in the moonlight...
...that the little swallow was filled with sadness for him.
They were filled with tears and tears were running down his golden face.
"Who are you?" He said.
"I am the Happy Prince."
"Why are you crying then?" Asked the swallow.
"When I was alive and had a heart," answered the statue,...
..."I did not know what tears were."
"Now that I am dead, they have put me up so high...
...that I can see all the ugliness and all the unhappiness in my city."
"That is making me cry."
"Far away," continued the statue,...
..."in a little street, there is a poor house."
"I can see a woman sitting at a table."
"Her face is thin and her hands hurt because she works all day sewing clothes for rich women to wear."
"In a bed in the corner of the room, her little boy is sick."
"Little swallow, will you please take her the jewel from the top of my sword?"
The Happy Prince looked so sad that the little swallow was sad, too.
"It is very cold here," he said,...
..."but I will stay with you for one night, and do as you ask."